In Belgium, European Council President Donald Tusk wants Britain to have until next April...
...to come up with a viable plan for its exit from the European Union.
Britain formally requested another exit extension until June 30.
In Algeria, thousands of Algerians demonstrated for the first time...
...since the resignation of ailing President Abdelaziz Bouteflika,...
...in a key test of whether the momentum for reform can be maintained.
In Libya, Eastern Libyan commander Khalifa Haftar...
...  ordered his troops to march on the capital, Tripoli,...
...escalating a conflict with the internationally recognized government.
In Greece, police fired tear gas to disperse migrants...
...who had gathered in a field near the country's border with northern Macedonia...
...in the hope of making their way illegally up through the Balkans towards northern Europe.
Finally from Turkey, the main opposition candidate in Istanbul's municipal election...
...said he remained ahead of his rival after a recount of invalid votes...
...in nearly half of the city's districts demanded by President Tayyip Erdogan's ruling AK Party.